today on our show DC trailers from home
yes like comic-con trailers from the DC
Universe coming right at you in our
opinion upset trailers today on five
dude good - hey ma'am look the fact now
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm Marc Bernard
we just got back from the San Diego
comic-con mm-hmm I was there to do a
bunch of things including interview
people from IMDB Marc was there for
bunch of things including the only time
sending the LA Times sent me down
Maurice [ __ ] big what I do [ __ ] use
don't use working and stuff like yeah
but uh we didn't we wouldn't be San
Diego without new trailers coming out
this year San Diego comic-con came down
to Marvel vs. DC and Hall H and we were
all winners you know each one who's like
my dicks big by Diggs big my that guy's
lasers Oh my dick has ego the Living God
it was fantastic they they really pulled
out all the stops man the DC versus
Marvel war benefits those of us that
want to see trailers well in advance
that's the only reason we got to see
Justice League [ __ ] like a year and a
half yeah total is because they're like
let's [ __ ] let's let's show him how
much nevermind just the tip all NECA and
then Marvel closed at the end of the day
well I was after them but whatever
Marvel closed in Hall H of the two big
movie universes with a gigantic [ __ ]
presentation which we'll talk about in
the next episode this episode all about
the DC Universe movie trailers and let
us start with the obvious of course the
big surprise was Justice League mark we
knew that they'd probably bring in the
cast from England and they would all
Queens wave as they did back in the day
I don't know why nobody thought that
they'd bring footage they showed those
journalists not too long ago so we
thought maybe we'd see maybe you'd see a
scene like the scene of Bruce Wayne
Barry Allen we read about who knew
they'd flat-out pulled together if I can
trailer a legit trailer man thoughts on
the trailer uh I loved that it was fun
yeah I loved that it was funny I loved
that they let Ben be funny because that
last movie not so much with the funny
yeah they're not was so funny and I
liked
Azra Miller more than I thought I would
I mean he's never gonna be my grand gosh
no there's this newer place and grant in
my heart I'm with you on that but I mean
he's so much fun yeah so much they
picked a portrayal to go with a flash
where you're like oh all right yeah you
know I'm saying it felt kind of like
they've got a flash on TV while you're
doing this but you know he made them a
bit different and it seems like he's
gonna be are like way in for laughs on
Justice League
it seems lighter but is what I'll say
that opening is phenomenal like that
opening with with Aquaman Bruce Wayne
looking for certain comes in on the King
to his man it comes to this village
rings fish you know for the hungry
everything he comes on the King Tut that
was last night but everything he says
about Arthur curry is heroic like
something that was missing in those last
two movies neither of them were
particularly heroic no nobody's a hero
in those movie no but in this movie
right I mean at least in the trailer
right away what he's describing our acts
of super heroism so I'm like oh
instantly I'm like yes this is familiar
terrain it's not about my [ __ ]
disliking each other and like I got to
stop him he's doing a narrative about
this guy who for no good reason comes
this village and brings him food when
they're hungry and [ __ ] like that is
weird because he's like he brings him
fish cookies from my quater Jesus that
[ __ ] shot man oh my god
beautifully painted with a see just
[ __ ] swallowing him up and [ __ ] like
that but he brings him fish this is the
thing that I was weirded out about so
he's the king of he talks to fish the
king of seas don't you think that's
[ __ ] I eat my friends yeah all of my
friend doesn't like you bringing humans
to like something that ate humans so
he's gotta listen to all the sounds of
the fish dying is a villager you can you
pay [ __ ] don't you love
um that was the only thing I thought
that was a little weird um but I love
that sequence so much like him going
listing he comes to this village and is
this really [ __ ] well done like that
right away they set the tone Reich say
like yes about people who put other
people before themselves and then little
dig at the endures like your name is
Arthur curry I hear you talk to fish yes
he talks the [ __ ] fish yes all of us
in the audience like you better talk to
Perce you gotta be like when a shorter
eat some [ __ ] man that's what I'm
looking for in the next movie
Aquaman Bruce Wayne meets hard to curry
right there that dude's big to man and
Santa Claus in the background can't look
I'm just doing it for good measure like
this is a good enough Christmas um what
else is in that trailer we'll get our
first good look at cyborg as spoken
about Ezra Miller's Flash is fun yeah
his suit is very PC there's what more
like the injustice gods among us there's
a lot of hard plastic going on totally
to say in this trailer uh look at it
that's a nice view of the suit right
there um looks like a transformer a
little bit yeah yeah I'd prefer that you
know the one that we see on TV every
week but you know what even beggars
can't be choosers heavens and look it
looks like they listened a great deal to
the audience because this movie seems at
least in at least as a place in this
trailer piece from comic-con the movie
that we were all hoping Batman be super
yeah
Superman was they seem to like each
other and there's a sense of humor you
know with more or less more more more or
less he said no he said no um like he
definitely felt like between this and
Wonder Woman course-correction
yeah like that was sort of the narrative
that I pulled out of sitting there with
the DC stuff was that they kind of
understood that the audience wanted
something different they understood that
we wanted more vendor still we wanted to
our heroes to be heroic our legends to
be legendary and so they just sort of
shifted a little bit now what else does
it play in the trailer we don't see a
hint of the villain yet although we know
it's Steppenwolf we see them bothering
up during burying a mother box in old
timey days or something like that what
else do we see yeah there it is we see
we don't see any Superman even
we don't see Superman but he's got to be
a part of this I mean they brought him
out onstage today Henry was there huh
he's like I'm still yeah they don't kill
me yet it's not Ben's movie yet they're
like you don't talk like that he's got
Pasha
did you see the that he crashed the
Suicide Squad signing on the floor and
we cattle did yeah he was wearing a V
for Vendetta mask and so he gets up
there too gets like this autographs from
everybody they didn't know who he was
until the very end he just pops in his
[ __ ] Superman and when he left to the
master like who are you jeesh and he was
like I'm I'm I'm I'm no Superman I just
walked away I'm your man of steel um
there were let's see what else I like
about the trailer
more Wonder Woman that's always a fine
thing within that we got a lot of Wonder
Woman's like it's all Wonder Woman
trailer which we'll get to in a sec um
they look at that [ __ ] dude more and
more of that look how can a man that's
[ __ ] who knew I look I always liked
Wonder Woman I didn't know how much I
liked one Wonder Woman until they start
putting her in movies [ __ ] outta people
like more of this more of that um who
else know Lex Luthor in the trailer no
seems like the plot is Batman's getting
the band back together although they've
never been together before how do you
feel about that like of all the
characters that should be bringing
people together like what I mean also
here's something I objected to like
Bruce Wayne shows up in your house
you're the flash hmm
like you know he's like ooh Barry Allen
Bruce Wayne he's like you say that like
it explains why a total stranger is
sitting in my second favorite chair how
is Bruce Wayne not insanely well known
in this world never Clark Kent and bbs
was like who's that like that's Bruce
Wayne dick yeah like you know you're a
reporter and that's the richest guy in
like a hundred thousand square miles I
don't know who that is
same thing here it's like Bruce Wayne
Bruce Wayne goes to a fishing village
even a poor fishing village in [ __ ]
Nova Scotia or wherever it isn't [ __ ]
people are gonna be like oh you're Bruce
Wayne like I've seen you in the
newspapers they see you pushing Turkish
Airlines all the time yeah
[ __ ] selling for turkeys yes so
that's what minor quibble but I don't
know that I would have made him the guy
who brings him together he's the dude
you've got to bring in last cuz he's
like I don't need he'll I mean I see the
two ways I see the Bruce Wayne is to do
with information so he's the guy who
knows where everybody is but then you
want him to be you know the last key
amid less piece of the puzzle but at the
same time it's also tying into that last
movie where it's like you know I failed
him in life I won't fail him and death
I'll be the one bringing everyone
together I'm super psychic now cuz
apparently I see the future for reasons
never actually explained or made clear I
believe there's rhyming I believe I need
to put together a team I believe last
movie wasn't as well accepted as we hope
I believe it's time for funds Oh Betty
yeah I believe it's time not a good time
so it cracks a joke at the encounter
right did you did you get the same
feeling that I got that the Bruce Wayne
Barry Allen scene wasn't quite as poppy
as the Iron Man spider-man scene where
Tony Stark goes to Queens to to recruit
a young geek in his weird lair and put
up a 2-shot cuz I didn't even see that
are you're you're absolutely right isn't
it paint if the same [ __ ] scene but
mark yeah you're gonna borrow borrow
from [ __ ] that we all like and already
[ __ ] approved you're right I guess
there's an older figure and a newer guy
who doesn't know that the old guy knows
who he is and what would Bruce pay for
the suit uh unclear he probably does
that's really that car man I'm still on
a fault I hadn't seen that good point
good pole that's what you get a writer
with mark phenomena but uh but I'll
don't give a [ __ ] yeah I mean just to
hear him say Barry Allen Bruce Wayne
just your [ __ ] Ben Affleck Oh Arthur
curry just throw those [ __ ] bands
around like please that [ __ ] makes me
feel good at least it's not like on a
computer pressing little mouse buttons
yeah they can't undo those No
so we can undo that part um but yeah I
think this is about him making up for
the other thing I didn't like you you
know he's like I believe there's a
something coming I believe and then when
he gets to flash he's just like you know
stop I'm in mmm and they show like
[ __ ] Bruce Wayne going really like
like a kid I understand like you know
he's probably been shot down by other
career and whatever the [ __ ] but I'd be
like really was just yeah I mean I
wouldn't do but whatever is from tiny
quibbles tiny quibbles and what
otherwise looks like a righted course
for the DC universe Batman slash
Superman franchise with all the DC
characters maybe he's actually
understand his level that look Zack
Snyder could not I mean there's the
thing I saw that trello I was like [ __ ]
yeah I take all my money said the same
thing after the first PBS trailers whoa
but that being said like Zack does in
this trailer what he does so amazingly
well paints a frame that [ __ ] shot of
Aquaman getting hit by the [ __ ] ocean
is gorgeous it's like [ __ ] stunning
man like doctor goddamn he is a shooter
man like that's [ __ ] beautiful right
there that made me so happy seeing that
like [ __ ] I never would have thought
of that I would have done a dick move
like him diving into the ocean or
something look I don't even know what's
going on but that's [ __ ] bad-ass ik
tostring and so it looks like we're
getting a lot more of that snyder
painting those beautiful panels but also
with luck character stuff that feels
closer to the Kiros we know right I
never thought you were real I'm real
when it's useful yeah on a bat [ __ ]
alright so I was happy with that
Charlotte and also very [ __ ]
surprised that they brought it and
that's like sha Shan a lot of us not
just showing just the tip that's showing
straight down to the balls like a year
and a half in advance and I think it was
a smart play max I like looking at that
dick I'm a dick looker and I like that
dick they showed us speaking of another
dick let's talk about Wonder Woman's
giant [ __ ] dick that they unfurled
for us in Hall H I'll say it right here
like I was always on board for this
movie cuz you know [ __ ] Mel see every
cop book movie and Wonder Woman hey it's
about time now I want to see this movie
now I'm not dutifully going because yay
comic books
the [ __ ] dude everything that I was like
[ __ ] on the fence about I'm off the
fence I used to be like or wore one why
would you or two and then you see the
trenches World War one Mother's Day and
adding each other and she climbs up that
ladder dude one of the greatest shots I
ever seen
there it is in my life is that [ __ ]
shot of her in the middle of the
battlefield clutching the [ __ ] shield
in front of her with the bent knees
while armaments for flying at her and
[ __ ] and she's like doesn't watering
away mortar fires oh [ __ ] that was
tremendous and so much like she got a
shield so I shouldn't be like hey
Captain America but I don't [ __ ]
think of that at all I'm like look at
her [ __ ] go the golden lariat magic
lasso [ __ ] lights the [ __ ] up like
Christmas like Chile lights you know in
a [ __ ] hipsters living room
oh my God look at [ __ ] man they're
getting right whose directors patty
Giada Junkins [ __ ] man she did monster
yeah take all my money patty Jenkins you
might got us now dude I had no [ __ ]
clue that they could make a really
interesting [ __ ] Wonder Woman movie
in World War one the character was born
in World War two if I remember correctly
wasn't wasn't sure yeah I think so
history I think something's maybe that
was one world worse they given her the
hundred years then yeah they would send
her back to a World War one oh dude I
can't wait man that [ __ ] all of the
action shots her like in that room of
like six eight soldiers [ __ ] shield
oh look at that [ __ ] right there man
that's [ __ ] dumb and I love that she
doing it in the outfit mm-hmm some
people on the internet to be like come
on she can't wear [ __ ] pants
that's not cool about it isn't all those
[ __ ] on the battlefield are covered
and had to tow these long [ __ ] coats
and armored to death and she [ __ ]
climbs that ladder and skinned and her
[ __ ] outfit her armor and [ __ ] and
just starts dude to death David oh dude
I watch that trailer probably twenty
times just for that [ __ ] moment ship
where she's just like bearing down and
taking the [ __ ] guns and [ __ ] this
movie's my jam do not no idea I [ __ ]
[ __ ] look here's a story I showed my
wife the Justice League trailer she's
like whatever I showed her the the
Doctor Strange trailer she's like
whatever I showed her wonder what
she's like we're going to see them I'm
here for wonder when I was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you I'm going to see regardless I
was always in the back of this you're a
[ __ ] carpetbagger I said she's like
fine I won't say was it go do that
no he fought me she goes we were gonna
go yeah this movie looks [ __ ]
tremendous man okay wait it was the
story of the con for me like I said I'm
glad that other people were so like how
do you think we were all just not
expecting it to be I mean I think we all
should've in Justice League man honestly
like they [ __ ] literally showed us
Justice League so that should have been
the buzz but like what I've been talking
about the most is [ __ ] Wonder Woman
when she's in one Justice League's that
counts but this Wonder Woman movie looks
[ __ ] awesome and they be [ __ ]
marvel to the solo girl hero pond yeah
the one thing they put herself of course
to be like weird meanwhile Marvel
announced cap Marvel brie Larson and
stuff but now they're just in that area
of female lead they're playing a little
bit of catch-up at this point yeah
hats off to that [ __ ] Wonder Woman
trail looking well done yeah really
[ __ ] well done a big bad way now I'm
alright now I want to see that movie for
the movie itself not just because I'm a
dutiful comic book fan
let's talk Suicide Squad they showed us
new footage but nothing really new
trailer and and all of these Suicide
Squad wants to look a gift horse in the
mouth
all these Suicide Squad trailers have
been epic works a standalone arc a heart
they're just wonderful every one of
those trailers you could sit there and
watch like a music video and [ __ ] like
that
so this trailer was no different than
used a lot of music from the soundtrack
that heathen song and stuff like that
they showed some new new footage but
generally it was so blurred in there it
was just like this orgy of sound and
vision have you heard what that movie's
supposed to open that 125 million
they're tracking it now that's now now
that's before the comp con weekend bump
where they released a bunch of new
footage and [ __ ] like that
and now they're inundating like their
commercials everywhere oh yeah and
they're gonna do the procedure Smith is
gonna go and do what Will Smith does
which is sell you on whatever Will Smith
is in either could get up to a hundred
fifty lots of 125 that's an offensive
like that is that bigger than [ __ ]
what a Batman V Superman open
domestically 136 I think could you
imagine if it got up there even here did
it beat it in some way shape or form
people would talk man it deserves it
because it's got people excited there
are people who don't even know comic
books can't wait to see this movie yeah
that's been a soft summer too so like
it's it's fertile ground they can end
strong it could book on the summer with
civil war and then suicides one boom um
okay so that looked cool let's talk
about the flash yeah he's in three on
the tele trailer on the television the
DC W if you will DC universe is
expanding all over [ __ ] CW now
they've got arrow flash legends of
tomorrow and Supergirl yes so boy
they've got tons and tons of stuff they
almost having a whole combo [ __ ] a whole
comic book store on every week like all
it is one more day mm-hmm they would
have five days a week would you imagine
dude this is [ __ ] we dreamed about we
were kids like why won't they have a
[ __ ] five comic book show Network now
they do now I do [ __ ] see that well
the wall this trailer for flash season
three was beautiful like emotional takes
you right like it brings back to the
closing premise of season two or Barry
stops the reverse flash from killing his
mom spoilers which sets up as everyone's
been going flash blind and what we learn
not so much from the trailer but look at
that [ __ ] there's parents together no
and she's causing my boy there's my
beautiful boy and they're alive and
together isn't seeing this since he was
appointed that made me [ __ ] him well up
all I was watching the trailer that made
me so emotional is it he's gonna see his
parents together you know like that
beautiful thing so but we all know
flashpoints not a beautiful thing at the
end of the day if I can't destroys
things but here's what we didn't know we
found out from being on the IMDB boat I
was talking to those cats about Flash
and I was like flash point and flash
point is episode 1 and then for the rest
of the season
it's repercussions so it's not a full
season of flashpoint like people were
okay they're gonna do Thomas wait no I
think they're doing this one episode and
then then it's dealing like with
reverberations okay Rob whatever it is
sounds badass Ben but I'm in I'm in a
bag for this in a big bed way we all
know how much I [ __ ] love the flash
and I go back to shoot episode 7 first
week in September
dr. alchemy it would seem like his arm
bad the season which is really [ __ ]
cool look at that she I mean yeah we'd
seen they literally wrote it on a mirror
or something for us to read um what else
did they show us uh wall-e in the flash
college kid flash now I don't know if
that's I guess that would be all - there
he is
I guess that'd be alternate world flash
that wouldn't be in our right world but
look at those glass buildings that's
[ __ ] Vancouver that's the van yeah
that's definitely the man um
man oh man this trailer looks fantastic
the whole season looks great
you know I can't wait I'm ready in for
the camping bad way but that trailer was
so well put together and so emotional
I'm just a bit what you see Joe like not
know who Barry is like why do you keep
falling around like you're my friend I'm
behind this - I almost cried when Irish
was just like do we know each other
did we have it and then later on she's
like wear something in your world aren't
we like ah and then later on there
Mackin like [ __ ] pros oh I think
lassies just talking about I cannot wait
to watch the [ __ ] first two three
episodes this is I can't wait to watch
them all but it's like bring them fast
it's September it's fades right around
in October that's when they did be oh
yeah early October what the [ __ ] man
I'll wait dude I'll wait a lifetime to
watch them [ __ ] well they got a
bigger steer clear of Luke Cage is that
what it is
drop September 30 yeah but that's a
Binger you watch that all at once
yeah but that's why the way into October
just give a little bit little space Luke
Cage when we talk about next steps or
all the Marvel stuff that all we got for
the DC stuff that's really the easy
stuff I mean there were arrow trailers
there were legends of tomorrow trailers
and in legends tomorrow next season
they're doing the Legion of Doom
which I'm not yes they do the base that
looks like the Darth Vader's I mean look
where Lance he already owns my
allegiance and soul but they [ __ ]
take it that far
oh my god we good I [ __ ] you take one
get it take my firstborn kiss you
seventeen manga should take her man you
earn it for doing Legion - um and dark
so much more I'll watch the Gotham
trailer for the next season - well you
and I have to jump back into gonorrhea
like that mr. frizzy don't say like is a
cottage man Marc be like do
it's not like eating beans or liver they
and they showed a lot of cool [ __ ] in
the trailer with Mr Freeze and Riddler
going Riddler ish and then like fish
Mooney came back whatever like there's
good it looks like there's good times we
had and got them I'm telling you we
gotta try it this is what's telling us
last season like you guys jumped off too
soon [ __ ] fries they're doing court
of owls in the Styx season looks like a
survey I think they're doing a deeper
more I am a court of owls do we need
Night Court of owls with ball every
about man a Mac there it is folks that
was sandy heir to the San Diego that was
2016 we watched a whole bunch of
trailers afterward eating about to go to
San Diego for these trailers yeah like
they put them up online 90 in it yeah
Warner Brothers is like take it off
socket Marvel Marvel was a bit more
cagey we this is how they put some out
but they kept others for themselves and
we'll talk about that on the next
episode a fat man on Batman until then
man I've been Kevin Smith I've been more
alert and uh come back next time same
fat time same fat channel SModcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith a man's
meet Kevin Smith thanks for watching do
me a favor click that thing below that
says subscribe every time you click that
you save a baby kitten from murder